Mr wayne you know you really
could be doing more for this city
your family has a history of philanthropy but
as far as i can tell you're not doing anything
if i'm elected i want to
change that thank you oh my god
i'm gonna go pay my respects will you
wait for me i want to continue this
excuse me chief can i talk to you
gil coulson is missing what he hasn't been heard
from since last night not again hey mr wayne
you got people looking for him jim
sent a couple guys to his house
nothing what does his wife say she hadn't heard
get back down
get out of the car and show your hands get out
christ it's colson there's a bomb around his chest
let's clear this place out now
The Batman
Welcome back everyone this will be
my new batman trailer video they released a nice
shiny hd quality version of this funeral scene so
there's a bunch of easter eggs we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we have to thank
matt reeves for appreciating quality video he put
up this nice shiny hd version of this because you
may have seen a potato quality version circulating
last week as sort of like a youtube pre-roll you
may have seen it as an ad either way what's going
on here is the woman talking to bruce wayne is
named bella real and she's the candidate for the
new mayor because the funeral that they're at is
for the old mayor that the riddler literally just
killed she's having this conversation with bruce
wayne about doing more philanthropy for the city
because he hasn't been giving money the same way
that his father thomas wayne did she kind of jokes
about his people quote-unquote telling him that
he's never available because he's spending all of
his time as batman that also gets into the idea of
where he's spending all of his money like he's not
around to take your call because he's literally
either asleep during the day for a couple hours
or he's running around the city in the batmobile
beating up criminals so all the money that he
has all his many many billions of dollars are
going right now to funding the batman not that
he thinks of that as philanthropy but it kind of
is philanthropy like he's trying to help the city
with his money just not in the way that everybody
would expect him to in different movies different
tv shows different comics have had different ways
of depicting the way bruce wayne spends all of his
billions of dollars and in most of the different
iterations of batman even though he comes off
being a little bit crazy a little bit unhinged
and loose with the way that he spends money on
batman gear armor weapons the like he's actually
a very shrewd business person just in general
he leaves most of the day-to-day running of his
empire to lucious fox in most versions of the
character so even though christopher nolan had
that whole dark knight rises twist where he ran
the company to near bankruptcy funding the special
reactor in what happened with bane trying to
bankrupt him completely you have to kind of take
that as an elseworlds non-canonical aspect of his
mythology despite the dark knight trilogy being
a really solid trilogy the way they treated the
bruce wayne batman character during dark knight
rises was very divisive especially the way they
ended the movie for the most part the movies the
comics try not to dwell too much on how much money
batman has because on a technical level it's not
super interesting he's supposed to have unlimited
money effectively it's more interesting to see
what he spends his money on but at this point
in his career batman year two robert pattinson
actually said that the way he sees the character
bruce wayne almost doesn't exist as a person like
he spends all of his time as batman he doesn't
care about keeping up the bruce wayne persona
for appearances or public social discourse he's
purely a nocturnal creature living in gutter-like
conditions like living in squalor almost robert
pattinson actually said he's essentially living in
the gutter but what he meant by that is he seems
like he's living in the gutter like he's spending
all of his time in the new batcave which he
creates inside the abandoned subway terminal built
by his ancestors the wayne family it's literally
called the wayne terminus and it seems like the
entrance is through the graveyard which is a very
batman thing to do drive through a graveyard every
night just to get back to the bat cave in wayne
manor his actual house the actual mansion doesn't
really get used that much like it exists it
seems like he's in the mansion here in this scene
but you can tell he hasn't really done anything
with it since his parents died many years ago
and it's starting to seem kind of like a gray
garden situation like if you didn't know that he
was batman you only knew him as bruce wayne never
seeing him out during the day never really seeing
him giving interviews you'd think that he'd gone
full gray gardens so he's kind of living in filth
and squalor at this point not really taking
care of himself he doesn't really refine the
bruce wayne billionaire playboy persona till much
later in his career the little boy that everyone's
talking about in this scene is the mayor's son
there were a lot of you asking a couple of my
previous batman videos if he was meant to be dick
grayson or the new version of robin because there
were rumors last year that matt reeves might
introduce a version of robin at some point in
the new batman trilogy but this kid is not meant
to be the new robin he is just the mayor's son
and the reason why bella real says oh god jesus
when she sees him is because she's just concerned
on his behalf that the mayor left behind this
little kid in the gruesome circumstances behind
the mayor's death the riddler killing this little
kid's father and bruce wayne's reaction is him
identifying with a little kid having a mini ptsd
flashback to his parents being killed by joe chill
in crime alley he sees himself in this little kid
even though this scene is from the joker movie and
it's not meant to be robert pattinson's bruce
wayne i'm just using the footage because it's
the same basic concept crime alley thomas wayne
martha wayne the pearls and that's why he saves
the little kid when the lincoln navigator comes
crashing in like you can see him grab the kid
the scene is also meant to connect with the
riddler plot about the gotham city orphanage
and what happened to riddler as a child there's a
big chart board with all the different pieces of
evidence connecting them as children they haven't
fully revealed everything in the trailers but you
can see that one of the reasons why he hates the
wayne family thomas wayne in is now targeting
bruce wayne they imply something terrible happened
to him at the orphanage and he blames thomas wayne
for not doing something about it or thomas wayne
was funding the gotham city orphanage and maybe
thomas wayne was somehow partially responsible
for some tragedy that befell all these kids
so the scene is meant to be another metaphor for
childhood trauma linking batman's childhood in
riddler's childhood then when gordon is talking
to the other police officers about gil coulson
he says his wife has been asking them where he's
been because he's been missing for days and they
make it sound like this is a regular thing for him
like gil coulson is the current district attorney
played by peter sarsgaard he said that his
character is supposed to be a really bad guy so
it sounds like he goes on benders for days all the
time and is somehow abusing his power inside the
justice system and that's why the riddler targets
him next because just as gordon is getting on gil
coulson's case with the other police officers ian
crashes the lincoln navigator and it's revealed
the next victim is gil coulson himself like
jesus that's gil coulson in a very saw-like trap
involving a riddle about justice this is the
riddler up here on the balcony giving the clue
most of you probably detected that a lot of the
different riddler traps where he's killing all
these different powerful figures in gotham is a
lot like the traps in the saw movie where he traps
people who got away with crimes in real life
or did something terrible and got away with it
the difference in the batman movie is that batman
has to solve the riddle to try and save the people
but as you can probably tell in most cases at
least the early victims here all wind up dying the
reason why it seems like there are so many people
still in the room though even though there's this
giant bomb about to blow up is because they're all
meant to be part of the police department it's not
like a bunch of regular people are standing around
a bomb and they do clear the room out a little
later the other trailers actually show you what
happens later in the scene with the bomb exploding
in his face while he's wearing the batman suit
so it sounds like the scene goes on for quite a
bit longer after this long enough for bruce wayne
to rush out suit up as batman then come back how
quickly can you change clothes without being
detected and speaking of batman related stuff
talking about the joker i did a joker sequel
movie video because there's talk about them
doing a sequel to the joaquin phoenix joker movie
and even though this batman franchise is not meant
to connect with the joaquin phoenix joker movies
there are a lot of theories that barry keoghan's
mystery character in the movie is a version of
the joker he's supposedly playing a character in
arkham asylum that appears in a scene when batman
is visiting riddler and it's just a really short
scene but he's supposed to have this joker-like
hyena laugh and that's it so a lot of people are
thinking that he might be matt reeves version of
the joker or maybe we'll see more of him in the
batman 2 or whatever they call the sequel some of
the cuts of the movie supposedly have this barry
keoghan joker-like scene and some of the cuts do
not have it so we'll see whether or not it makes
it into the actual final theatrical cut but i do
think there will be some easter eggs for joker
inside this first batman movie or at least some
small references if you spotted any easter eggs in
the trailer or the clip that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
and i will do more joker videos if we get more
news about what's happening with that character
inside the dc eu in the future everyone click
here for that joker 2 movie announcement video
and click here for my new halo tv series trailer
that's right they're doing a full-blown halo
tv show thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!